and we're just breaking into our
coverage uh to take you straight to the
white house to listen to president biden
over the issues of afghanistan to
provide the american people with a brief
update and this on the situation in
afghanistan
since i spoke to you on monday we've
made significant progress
we've secured the airport enabling
flights to resume
not just military flights but civilian
charters and other from other countries
and the ngos taking out
civilians and vulnerable afghan
vulnerable afghanis
and now we have almost 6 000 troops on
the ground including the 82nd airborne
providing runway security
the army 10th mountain division standing
guard around the airport
and the 24th marine expeditionary unit
assisting the civilian departure
this is one of the largest most
difficult airlifts in history
and the only country in the world
capable of projecting this much power
on the far side of the world with this
degree of precision is the united states
of america
we've already evacuated more than 18 000
people since july and approximately 13
000
since our military lift began
on august the 14th
thousands more have been evacuated on
private charter flights facilitated by
the u.s government
these numbers include american citizens
and permanent residents as well as their
families
it includes siv applicants and their
families
those afghans who have worked alongside
us
served alongside of us
gone into combat with us and provided
invaluable assistance to us such as
translators and interpreters
the united states stands by its
commitment that we've made to these
people and includes other vulnerable
afghans such as women leaders and
journalists
in fact working in close coordination
with the management of the new york
times the washington post and wall
street journal
we have successfully evacuated all 204
of their employees in afghanistan on u.s
military aircraft earlier this week
we've established the flow of flights
and we've increased the number of people
we're moving out of the country
we paused flights in kabul a few hours
this morning
to make sure we could process the
arriving evacuees at their transit
points
but our commander on kabul has already
given the order for outbound flights to
resume
even with the pause we've moved out 5
700 evacuees yesterday and we're working
on a variety
uh to verify that number of the
americans are still in country as we
work on this because we're not don't
have the exact number of people who are
americans are there and those who may
have come home to the united states
we're not we want to get a strong number
as to exactly how many people are there
how many american citizens and where
they are just yesterday
among the many americans we evacuated
there were 169 americans
who over the we've got over the wall
into the airport using military assets
we're also facilitating flights for our
allies and our partners
and working in close operational
coordination with nato
on this evacuation
for example
we provided overwatch for the french
convoy bringing hundreds of their people
from the french embassy
to the airport
these operations are going to continue
over the coming days before we complete
our drawdown
we're going to do everything everything
that we can to provide safe evacuation
for our afghan allies
partners and afghans who
who
might be targeted if because of their
association with the united states
but let me be clear
any american who wants to come home
we will get you home
make no mistake this evacuation mission
is dangerous it involves risks to our
armed forces and it's being conducted
under difficult circumstances
i cannot promise what the final outcome
will be or what it will be that it will
be without risk of loss
but as commander-in-chief
i can assure you that i will mobilize
every resource necessary
and as an american i offer my gratitude
to the brave men and women of the u.s
armed forces are carrying out this
mission they're incredible
as we continue to work the logistics of
evacuation we're in constant contact
with the taliban working to ensure
civilians have safe passage to the
airport
we're particularly focused on our
engagements on making sure every
american
who wants to leave can get to the
airport
where we have been seeing challenges
with americans for for americans we have
thus far been able to resolve them
we've been able we've made look
and we
we've made clear to the taliban that any
attack
any attack on our forces or disruption
of our operations the airport will be
met with swift and forceful response
we're also keeping a close watch on any
potential terrorist threat
at or around the airport including
from the isis affiliates in afghanistan
who were released from prison when the
prisons were emptied
and because they are by the way and make
everybody understand that the the isis
in afghanistan are this have been the
sworn enemy of the taliban
i've said all along
we're going to retain a laser focus on
our counter-terrorism mission
working in close coordination with our
allies and our partners
and all those who have an interest in
ensuring stability in the region
secretary blinken is with me today met
this morning with our nato allies in
consultation about the way forward
so that afghanistan cannot be used as a
in the future
as a terrorist base of attacking to
attack the united states or our allies
for 20 years afghanistan has been a
joint effort with our nato allies
we went in together
and we're leaving together
and now we're working together to bring
our people and our afghan partners to
safety
in the past few days
i've also spoken directly with the
british prime minister mr johnson
chancellor merkel of germany
and president macron of france
we all agreed
that we should convene and we will
convene the g7 meeting next week
a group of the world's leading
democracies so that together we can
coordinate our mutual approach our
united approach on afghanistan and
moving forward
we are united with our closest partners
to execute the mission at hand
we've also discussed the need to work
with the international community to
provide humanitarian assistance such as
food aid and medical care for refugees
who have crossed into neighboring
countries to escape the taliban
and to bring international pressure on
the taliban with respect
to the treatment of afghan
afghan people overall but including
afghan particularly women and girls
the past week has been heartbreaking
we've seen gut-wrenching images of
panicked people acting out of sheer
desperation
you know it's completely understandable
they're frightened
they're sad
uncertain what happens next
i don't think anyone i don't think any
one of us can see these pictures and not
feel that pain
on a human level
now we have a mission a mission to
complete in afghanistan
it's an incredibly difficult and
dangerous operation for our military
we have almost 6 000
of america's finest fighting men and
women and at the kabul airport
and we're putting their lives on the
line and they're doing it in a dangerous
place
to save other americans our afghan
allies and citizens of our our li our
allies who went in with us
you know i i talk
i talked to our commanders on the ground
there every single day
as i just did a few hours an hour or so
ago
and i made it clear to them that we'll
get them whatever they need to do the
job
they're performing to the highest
standard under extraordinarily difficult
and dynamic circumstances
our nato allies
are strongly standing with us
their troops keeping century alongside
ours in kabul
as is the case
whenever i deploy our troops into harm's
way
i take that responsibility seriously
i carry that burden every day
just as i did when i was vice president
my son was deployed to iraq for a year
there'll be plenty of time to criticize
and second guess when this operation is
over
but now
now
i'm focused on getting this job done
i would ask every american
to join me in praying for the women and
men
risking their lives on the ground in the
service of our nation
as events evolve
over the coming days
my team and i will continue to share the
information and update the american
people on exactly where things are
we'll use every resource necessary to
carry out the mission at hand
and bring to safety american citizens
and our afghan allies
this is our focus now
and when this is finished
we will complete our military withdrawal
and finally bring to an end
20 years of american military action in
afghanistan
thank you may god bless you our troops
our diplomats and all those serving in
harm's way
and now i'll take questions ap
zeke miller
[Music]
afghanistan but you also promised
not to to help to bring out those who
helped america in its war effort we've
seen these heart-wrenching images at the
kabul airport of people trying to get
there say nothing of the people who
can't get to that airport you made the
commitment to get american troops out to
get again american citizens out will you
make the same commitment to those who
assisted in the american war effort over
the last 20 years number one
and then number two what is your message
to the america's partners around the
world who have criticized not the
withdrawal but the conduct of that
withdrawal and made it made them
question america's credibility on the
world stage i have seen no question of
our credibility from our allies around
the world
i've spoken with our nato allies we've
spoken with nato allies the the
secretary of state our national security
adviser has been in contact with his
counterparts throughout the world and
our allies as has
the general or excuse me i keep calling
them in general but my secretary of
defense
the fact of the matter is i have not
seen that matter of fact the exact
opposite i've gotten
the exact opposite thing is we're acting
with dispatch we're acting committing to
what we said we would do look let's put
this thing in perspective here
what interest do we have in afghanistan
at this point with al qaeda gone
we went to afghanistan for the express
purpose of getting rid of al qaeda in
afghanistan as well as as well as
getting osama bin laden and we did
imagine just imagine if
that attack if bin laden had decided
with al qaeda to launch an attack from
yemen
would we ever gone to afghanistan
would there ever be any reason we'd be
in afghanistan
controlled by the taliban
what is the national interest in the
united states in that circumstance
we went and did the mission you've known
my position for a long long time
it's time to end this war
the estimates of the cost of this war
over the last 20 years range from a
minimum one trillion dollars
to a think tank at one of the
universities saying two trillion that's
somewhere between 150 million dollars a
day and 300 million dollars a day
the threat from terrorism has
metastasized
there's a greater danger from isis and
and and and al qaeda and all these
affiliates in other countries by far
than there is from afghanistan and we're
going to retain on over the rising
capability that if they were to come
back to be able to take them out
surgically move
so this is this is where we should be
this is about america leading the world
and all our allies have agreed with that
and by the way before i made this
decision
i was at the g7
as well as met with our
nato partners
and i told them all every one of them
knew and agreed with the decision i made
to and end and jointly end our
involvement in afghanistan the first
part of your question was i can't
remember now
would you commit to the same commitment
would you make the same commitment to
bring out afghans who assisted in the
war efforts yes yes we're making the
same commitment there's no one more
important than bringing american
citizens out i acknowledge that
but they're equally important almost as
all those who those sivs we call them
who in fact helped us there were
translators they went in the battle with
us they were part of the operation
as well as we're also trying to get out
as many ngos non-government
organizations women's organizations etc
we're doing all we can in the meantime
uh secretary blinken and i am going to
be working with our allies to see to it
that we can bring international pressure
on the taliban to be they're looking to
gain some legitimacy
they're going to have to figure out how
they're going to maintain that country
and there's going to be harsh conditions
where strong conditions we're going to
apply and will depend on whether they
get help based on whether or not how and
well they treat women and girls how they
treat their citizens so this is just
beginning on that score
they passed the 31st to make that happen
to bring all the americans out to bring
those sivs out i think we can get it
done by then but we're going to make
that judgment as we go now justin sink a
bloomberg
thank you mr president
you just said that you would keep a
laser focus on counterterrorism efforts
and that you don't see as great of a
threat of terrorism from afghanistan as
other parts of the world but if you and
your administration so badly misassessed
how quickly the taliban would sweep
through afghanistan and we no longer
have an embassy there from which to run
intelligence operations how can you at
all be confident of your assessment of
the risk of terrorism
and the ability of the us to conduct
over the horizon missions to keep it in
check can you tell americans that
they're safe and will remain safe from
terror attacks in afghanistan
i think you're comparing apples and
oranges
one question was whether or not
the afghan forces we trained up
would stay and fight
in their own civil war they had going on
no one
shouldn't say no one the consensus was
that it was highly unlikely that in 11
days they'd collapse and fall the leader
of afghanistan would flee the country
that's a very different question than
whether or not
there is the ability to observe whether
or not large groups of
terrorists begin to accumulate in a
particular area in afghanistan to plot
against the united states of america
that's why we retained an over the
horizon capability to go in and do
something about that if that occurs
if that occurs but in the meantime we
know it's happened around the world we
know what's happening in terms of what's
going on
in other countries where there is the
significant rise
of terrorist organizations in the middle
east in east africa and other places and
so
the bottom line is we have to do we're
dealing with those terrorist threats
from other parts of the world in failed
states without permanent military
without without permanent military
presence there we have to do the same in
afghanistan
sir just on that initial assessment we
we learned
over the last 24 hours that there was a
descent cable from the state department
sure
saying that the taliban would come
faster
through afghanistan can you say why
after that cable was issued the u.s
didn't do more to get americans all
kinds of cables all kinds of advice if
you notice
that range from
this group saying that they didn't say
it fall when it would fall when it did
fall
but
saying that it would fall to others
saying it wouldn't happen for a long
time and they'd be able to sustain
themselves through the end of the year
i made the decision
the buck stops with me
i took the consensus opinion the
consensus opinion was that in fact it
would not occur if it occurred until
later in the year
so it was my decision
but now my i got my next is uh stephanie
ramos abc
thank you mr president two questions for
you the military has secured the airport
as you mentioned but will you sign off
on sending u.s troops into kabul to
evacuate americans who haven't been able
to get to the airport safely
we have no indication that they haven't
been able to get in kabul through the
airport we've made an agreement with the
with the taliban thus far they've
allowed them to go through it's in their
interest for them to go through
so we know of no circumstance where
american citizens are carrying an
american passport are trying to get
through to the airport but we will do
whatever needs to be done to see to it
they get to the airport and one more mr
president last month my colleague martha
raddatz interviewed abdul an interpreter
who was on the front lines with u.s
forces in afghanistan
overnight we received a photo of taliban
militants coming to the door
of his home literally hunting him down
thankfully he was able to escape but he
is obviously still in mortal danger
what would be your message to abdul his
wife and his three young daughters
we want you to be able to get to the
airport contact us we'll see whatever we
can do to get you there we've got to get
you out we are committed to deal with
you your wife and your child to get all
three of you out of afghanistan
that's the commitment
thank you sir meredith lee
of pbs newshour
you mentioned just now using every
resource available for evacuations why
haven't you ordered the military to
expand the security perimeter around the
kabul airport do you have any plans to
do so giving that will likely require
more u.s troops and are you considering
rescue operations to recover americans
and afghan allies stuck behind taliban
checkpoints
the last answer is yes to the last
question we're considering every op
every opportunity and every means by
which we could get
folks to the airport that's number one
number two
the reason why we have not gone out and
started and set up a perimeter
way outside the airport in kabul is that
it's likely to draw an awful lot of uh
unintended consequences in terms of
people who in fact
are not
part of the taliban we've been in
constant contact with the taliban
leadership on the ground in
in kabul
as well as the taliban leadership at
tahoe and we've been coordinating what
we're doing that's why we were able for
example
how we got all of our embassy personnel
out how we got everyone out of the
embassy safely that was the distance
that's how we helped get the french out
and out of their embassy so
the question remains there will be
judgments made on the ground by the
military commanders at the moment
and that i cannot second guess each of
those judgments to be made but
the idea of
again let me let me get back to the
fundamental point i i made at the outset
when
the decision was made
by me
that and it was made some time ago and i
ran four presidents saying i wanted to
get us out of afghanistan
one of the things that
is a reality is people now say
to me and to others and so many of you
say it on air
that
why did we have to move because no
americans are being attacked
why did we withdraw those why do we
agree to withdraw 500 troops no
americans have been attacked
as i said before
the reason they weren't being attacked
was part of an agreement that trump had
made
a year earlier
we will leave by may 1st he said as long
as there's no attack on americans in
that year period
number one number two the taliban was
taking large swaths of the countryside
north and south
none of the major
areas none of the major uh
points of the the capitals of each of
these provinces
but they were all over the all over the
country
and the idea
that if i had said on
may the second or third
we are not leaving we are staying
does anybody truly believe
that i would not have had to put in
significantly more american forces
send your sons your daughters like my
son was sent to iraq
to maybe die
and for what
for what
so the only rational thing to do in my
view
was to set up and pre-position american
forces
for the purpose of evacuation and the
aircraft to pre-position those ahead of
time
so that we would be able to begin the
process
of evacuation
of american citizens
sivs and others who helped us
the last point i'll make is this look um
if we had decided 15 years ago
to leave afghanistan
it would have been
really difficult
if we decided five years ago
if we started we continued the war for
another decade and tried to leave
there's no way in which
you'd be able to leave afghanistan
without there being some of what you're
seeing now
but what we've done so far
has been able to get a large number
of americans out all our personality
embassy out and so on and thank god so
far
knock on wood
we're in a different position
scott
detrow scott
npr
thank you mr president i just want to
follow up on something you said a moment
ago you said that there's no
circumstances where american citizens
cannot get to the airport
that doesn't really square with the
images we're seeing around the airport
with the reporting on the ground from
our colleagues who are describing chaos
and violence are you saying
unequivocally that any american who
wants to get to the airport is getting
there and getting past the security
barrier and to the planes where they
want to go i thought the question was
how can they get through to the airport
outside the airport
and the answer is the best of our
knowledge
the taliban checkpoints they are letting
through
people showing american passports now
that's a different question when they
get into the rush and crowd of all the
folks just outside the wall near the
airport that's why we had to i guess yet
was it yesterday a day before
we went over the wall and brought in how
many
169 americans
so it is a process to try to figure out
how we
how we
um
deal with the mad rush
of
non-americans those who didn't help
those who are not on the priority list
just any afghan any afghan to be able to
get out of the country and so my guess
is that no matter what under what
circumstance we
anyone there's not a whole lot of
afghanis uh there's a whole lot of
afghanis that just as soon come to
america whether there are any
involvement with the united states in
the past at all rather than stay under
taliban rule or any way and any rule so
what i was saying is that we have an
agreement
that they will let pass through
the checkpoints
that they the taliban control
the americans through but given this
given the negotiations with the taliban
the scenes that we're saying can you
just fully explain why
uh the plan wasn't to go ahead with
these evacuations of both americans and
allies before the drawdowns began before
bagram was closed looking back several
months because whether it was now or
several months from now there seems to
be a broad consensus that the taliban
would make these gains and these would
be needed at some point
well yeah at at some point
but the point was that although we were
in contact with the taliban and doha for
this whole period of time
that some point wasn't expected to be
the total demise of the afghan national
force
which is 300 persons let's assume the
afghan national force had continued to
fight
and and they were surrounding kabul
be very different story very different
story
but the overwhelming consensus was that
they this was not they were not going to
collapse the afghan forces they were not
going to leave they were not going to
just abandon and then put down their
arms and take off
so that's what happened
thank you very very much
you're watching al jazeera english there
joe biden flanked by the vice president
kamala harris the secretary of state
anthony blinken and lloyd austin the
defense secretary explaining the current
situation in afghanistan the evacuation
process